there you are did you make another child
cry oh it's not my fault the kids are
cry baby
you're an you are an we
are going right to Mi the a-hole from
Bob says hey Matt I have two Mia Hall
questions I travel occasionally for work
and I spent some time in Kentucky when I
return home to Ohio I apparently brought
a stink bug back with me and my luggage
the stink bug kept appearing randomly in
our house
and my daughter who loves bugs gave it a
name Roger
my wife wanted me to get rid of the
stink bug or put it outside in the
freezing cold to die and I refused it's
not hurting anyone and keeps to itself
poor bug has traveled across two states
and successfully hit in our house for a
month and my daughter even named it so I
told my wife I would not let it go until
it gets warmer outside I know this is a
weird story but am I the a-hole for
allowing it to live peacefully in our
home uh you're the a-hole for making me
read that entire thing thinking that
there was some sort of good punch line
like why am I reading why am I spending
it felt like hours reading that story
about a stink bug in your house and
there's no like I thought the punchline
it ended up in somebody's food and they
ate it or like something like that just
just kill the bug it's a bug all right
just just you don't want stink bugs in
your house okay those of us who have had
you know real estate we've lived in in
parts of the country that have a real
stink bug problem and we've had them in
the house it's it's not cute okay just
kill a damn Punk and it'll be fun they
don't have they don't have feelings
anyway they're not self-aware
um it makes no difference to the stink
bug whether it's alive or dead so I
don't know if that makes you feel any
better but that's just what you should
do my second question is a little
different me and my dad are both huge
fans of the daily wire and especially
you I'm a paying member my dad is not he
listens to the free shows on YouTube
every day he really wants to see your
movie what is a woman but I refuse to
let him use my membership to watch it
and tell him if he wants to see it then
he should support the company and get a
membership am I the a-hole for not
letting him be a bum and watch it for
free or should you have to pay for the
membership also this is not a situation
where you can't afford a membership he's
just being cheap okay that's a much
better story because it all comes back
to me so it makes it more interesting
um no you're not available
uh obstacle for your father and he's a
big fan uh and a supporter then he
should get the membership
stop being a cheap ass you can tell him
I said that did you notice that big tech
companies today are mass grading as
private companies are we supposed to
believe that a big Tech wolf has now
turned into our sweet Grandma big Tech
literally feeds on your information by
collecting and selling off your data
they can't stop themselves from looking
at what you do online that's why to
protect myself against big Tech's prying
eyes I use expressvpn when using the
expressvpn app on your computer or your
phone you're hiding your unique IP
address websites can't use that address
to find out your real location or track
what you do online on top of that
Expressway event encrypts and reroutes
100 of your online activity so your
internet provider Wi-Fi admin and
hackers can't see it best part though is
how easy it is to use it just takes one
click to protect all your devices one
expressvpn subscription covers up to
five devices at the same time so you can
protect your entire family too so
today's the day get the VPN that I trust
to protect my online privacy with big
bad Tech is at the door visit
expressvpn.com Walsh right now to get
three months for free that's expressvpn
Walsh to get protected expressvpn.com
Walsh
from Zachary Dear Matt my wife and I got
married after only knowing each other
for a few months I told her we should
wait but she insisted she had three kids
going in and I have one everything went
fine until it came time for parenting
strategies to present themselves both
our sons had suffered tremendously
mentally from what I believe was our
inability to be cohesive I told my wife
we needed to be firm and what we agreed
upon together is how to parent and not
sway I would periodically find out that
she would not enforce our rules when I
wasn't around which resulted in many
arguments behind closed doors ultimately
told her that I couldn't do this anymore
if things wouldn't change the deciding
event was when my son was physically
beaten up by her son and she believed
her son acted in self-defense to which I
reiterate that we don't condone violence
of any kind in our household and both
should be punished she didn't agree so I
declared that I wanted a divorce and
swiftly moved out with my son am I the
a-hole uh yes yes you are
um I'm as always with these things I
must uh
begin with a disclaimer that I'm only
getting one side of the story but but in
this case like I'm getting your side of
the story and um so I have to assume
that you're giving me the most generous
version of events most generous to
yourself because that's what people tend
to do right and even based on that I
would say that uh yeah you are being a
whole on a on a number of levels Zachary
uh first of all you don't threaten
divorce like that you don't use it as a
you don't use it as a weapon in an
argument
um and and you did that and you use it
as a weapon argument over over parenting
strategies which is the kind of thing
that of like every married couple has
disputes about that okay they might be
uh some disputes are more serious than
others depending on
what the you know what exactly is the
subject of it but but every married
couple this is this is like a attention
that you have you're different people
and so you have you'll have slightly
different ideas about uh how to parent
and what's the best way to handle
certain situations and you know what
should punishments be and what sort of
things should be punished and all that
kind of stuff to throw out a divorce
threat
is way over the line and then you
actually moved out of the house and said
you want a divorce because you disagreed
on a parenting thing I mean you're
married you made a You made a vow to
this woman
you made a promise
and that's supposed to mean something
okay it should mean something because
you made the promise and you made the
vow you should also want to demonstrate
to your son
uh what it means to be a man of your
word and so you fight for your marriage
and and you try to work through this
it's not like what you've told me about
here this is not there's nothing about
this that's uh really you know we hear
about irreconcilable differences which I
don't I don't believe in that really but
but uh this definitely is not
irreconcilable and also I got to tell
you
um I think you're wrong too when it
comes to this situation with your with
your uh your son and uh at first I mean
it's a problem that you're referring to
is her son and my son okay uh you're
married so they should both be your sons
but this dispute between the two boys I
think you're wrong on this
um now I don't know who's actually a
fault I have no idea but if it's true
that your son attacked his brother
and that his brother was defending
himself then that matters I don't know
if it is true but you're actually you're
saying it doesn't matter at all that if
you engage in violence at all you're
equally punished really so if a kid goes
along and instigates it and and
initiates the Violence by punching
another kid in the face and that kid
responds you think they both should be
equally punished as if they're both
equally in the wrong they clearly are
not equally in the wrong it does matter
who started it this idea that it doesn't
matter it doesn't matter who started
what do you of course it matters who
started this now if someone else starts
it it doesn't mean that whatever you do
in response is automatically Justified
but it does matter who started that is
it that is a detail that really matters
it matters morally I mean it if in the
court a court of law situation it
matters legally uh and it should matter
so I just think you're
wrong across the board I got to be uh
totally honest with you
all right finally from Dan says Matt you
seem like the best person to ask if I'm
the uh the because my situation
is about a conversation about a video on
YouTube an acquaintance of mine posted a
group chat a group chat that her tedx
presentation was Live on YouTube
she asked people to check it out like
comment and share the message was during
the work day and I write code for work
after about 40 minutes after she sent
the news I had a moment where I could
listen to the video while I worked I
noticed that the tedx people made a
mistake when editing the video and left
a portion that was not supposed to be
there the bit that shouldn't have been
included showed the the acquaintance
getting upset with herself or missing up
her messing up her line then it cuts to
her repeating herself and saying her
lines correctly I sent the following
message quote around 503 they left in a
part where you get upset with yourself
for messing up I recognize that my
message was short and I'm not a YouTuber
I don't know the level of involvement in
fixing and editing error I intended to
provide the exact time stamp and the
issue as quickly as possible so that she
could have the necessary information if
she would contact them to fix it her
response was quote you're actually the
worst actually
I let things go but someone else said
why sometimes we should just keep things
to ourselves I responded I figured maybe
they could fix it I understand how my
messages brevity could be misinterpreted
am I the a-hole for not spending more
time to develop a longer message maybe
on the a-hole because I shouldn't have
been I shouldn't have provided any
feedback unless I also had the time to
write a lengthy response that included
uplifting language ultimately even
though I can understand how my message
could be misinterpreted I don't think
her reaction could be interpreted in any
other way other than root you make
videos constantly for public consumption
do you think my feedback is helpful at
all
um
this this is a hard one for me to judge
actually I know you think that I'm
perfectly want to judge because I make
content all the time and so I get
feedback from people all the time and
that's true but that also has made me
I'm just I'm not a normal person when it
comes to this kind of because I I put
creative content out into the world
every single day and so um for most
people you know she did a tedx and she
felt very excited about it and this
might be the first time she's ever had a
video that's on YouTube right and uh and
so this was like a bigger deal to her
and so she wanted a bigger response now
I think putting you in a position where
you have to watch someone's tedx
presentation that already makes her the
a-hole like that's puts you in an
awkward spot and if you have a tedx
presentation yeah yeah your friends and
your family you can send it to them and
you can uh you can burden them with that
but to to put an acquaintance in a spot
where they have to watch it so like I'm
already kind of on your side because she
shouldn't have done it so she's she's
the a-hole just for that alone don't
like nobody wants to watch your tedx
talk nobody does uh but the only people
who should have to watch it are those
who are close to you but your
acquaintance you should you should make
them do that
um however because I make content all
the time I appreciate just like quick
basic feedback like that and if there's
an error somewhere or something
something that needs to be cut out and
someone says oh you know you messed up
that part like I'm fine with that
because I don't need I don't need all
the big speech I don't need you to
pretend I don't need your well that was
great I loved it no just get to the
point like if there's something there
that I can change if you're like just
tell me okay
um that's how I feel about it but I
think for most people when you when you
make something creative it's uh it's
kind of a vulnerable spot you know
you're you're putting yourself out there
and uh so if you're gonna give feedback
especially if it's to a woman you know
then
if you want it to be received well then
yeah it does help to preface it with
something so you could have said
something like this was great you're
such a great public speaker
um by the way not sure if it's something
can be fixed but uh there's a there's a
little flub there at 503 maybe they can
cut it out something like that probably
would have been received a little bit
better
just just add the you know that's what
that's that's what they're looking for
it's just that she's looking for there's
only reason like nobody is the other
thing almost nobody really wants honest
feedback about anything nobody really
they say that but they don't really uh
they just want you to compliment it and
especially if it's something creative
like that they just want to be
complimented
um so
you're borderline I don't know I'll give
you a
you're it's a borderline on the edge but
she mainly but she she wins out as the
a-hole here for making you watch the
tedx in the first place that's how I
that's how I'm gonna King Solomon this
this thing
[Music]